ずっとパッツンだったんですけど最近ちょっと分け目を作った方がいいのかなと思って
日々
ウザされております
外れ社長です東京から帰って来ましたよって元も東京に出てやっと久しぶりに帰って
くれてをば満足ですあの今学校が彼やされる休みなんで
今後コイルローラーねしなきゃいけないことがたくさんあって武器以上に大切なんです
よねそこの部屋のまず皆さんにわかっててほしい
俺ね超越欲しいんだよ
で忙しいと言ってる奴ほど忙しくないっていうことはよく言われることなんですけど
まぁ実際忙しいん
忙しいって言っちゃいますのたってもた忙しくないとかいやそうとは限らない
そうなぜなら俺は本当にそりゃはいじゃあ今日はですねまぁ久しぶりに日本に猫背
静岡に入ってきてイトーヨーカドーで買ってきました全体動き
ドキドキ暮らしちゅうわけで日本お茶対処して強くのコミュニケーションとイブもうに
受賞しておりますそういう感じですねはいその体の恋黒いところがあっだ
全部入ってるって良いですねまぁ遊び方なんですけどまぁカードに書いてあるこの
気持ちより臓器を絶対負け鼻から入れますセイバーって入れないと
わーっ分かってるなあこういうの
ブーブーは勝手だけどブーブーやっぱダース5位
がどうすればいいな鳥取道じゃないかわかんないというのはお値段じゃないわけです
からだそうだそうだそうに違いない
ないすれば奴よくわかんないこれがファースこれカード化や母が食べたい
母なる実感入れるよね
ぷっん
よく使いますこれでもまつ毛だけ一人である奴じゃないんだよなぁ絶対誰かと一緒に
さあ前楽しみだった聞いてこれ帰ってきても遊ぶ人がいないからこういう年の差でしか
ない
ぶら下げればいいだけ別の味もわからない
私たちだってそれであってるかこれで大丈夫これであってますよ
だしこういうシャッターおもちゃみたいなよくやってよ
ちょっと雰囲気作りに電気していきますおおこわいこわい
この感じでいきました怖いねちょっと思ってる子学と嬉しいプランねすごい良い商品だ
と思ってるけどなんか youtube でこれで遊んでいる子供たちを見たんです
けどこういうのからねやっぱり臓器と体の作りを学んでいくっていうのはそう言いとだ
としたら多分実際に臓器を見る
ぞ多分気持ち悪すぎて泡吹いて倒れるかも知れませんねもう一度全自衛隊やレンチ
入れるのか
だーっ
そこはもすぐできるぞ
うるさいグルースティックアリーナー完成でございまーやってみますかねハ楽しみだね
僕はね
こういうガキどあっちゃうこういう子どもたちガス田ぽさ喋ってないからね
とても楽しみなんですよ i 勢いでさっそくやってみましょうまあね俺のぐらい
web になるとハートもこういうのマジガチャなんで僕は満3歳の時医者になり
たかったんで今後
始まっていうのね4仕上げやめろまずまずルーエだね何もわかんないんだぞ
らしづやしづですまず委ね人まだ何もわからないんですとりあえずカードってあげた
カードの
ちょっと書いてある体のパーツをうるさいよを見てで体のパーツを埋め込むっていう
感じです
で埋めとの時はピンじっとした使っちゃダメっていう感じです
やってみましょう
1番目と
ああこれは簡単なら右手ですりっっ
右で上げ真央ねバカノメデルさんねはいミールです
4消去に余裕次心臓です心臓まで余裕だねあかぴーセットだこうやって体の不思議を
勉強していけばとってうるさいで方心臓どこ
ここが
意外とわからないもんだね通していった珍象入りましたこういう感じでねどうぞパンツ
を入れていきます
ていた
これ楽しいのかな相次ぎ右のハイです右の配備にがはいということはこれか
名前で出しちゃダメなんで多分
use
度の入った ok です次暴行です次てい
腎臓ですよしとしまして次肝臓肝臓を大事する
ana
連絡に我
ビックリ村何もどう
そういったそういいんだよ
ブー
はぁ
はいないんだってちょ待ってなきゃ誰がに何入れないんだもう詰まって売って払ってる
でしょあってるって言ってるなんて何で違っちゃった範囲内かいない
むにむにミリー
打つ気にしましょうこういうので次でいてをカードが好きなのガリレオしたいことをし
たい
俺すれば好きなことできていきたいルールにとらわれない理由これ難しいぜまずであ
ぶー思っちゃったちょっとこれ難しいよ
それとか絶対2位ジャン何かわかんないけど入れてみようそうだ声が入れていかなきゃ
いけないんだ
次々はいもねぇ絶対入れなきゃいけない回入った次恋来
ねーなーや家ついて味らしい汗てでて手汗足汗みんなもうクリアできそうです
頑張りましょうもうすぐだから仲間で全体向けここだ
[音楽]
あー4位
しています